[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance warmest condolences and
sympathies will not suffice we need
leadership in this country which will
prevent whatever their motive the
terrorists in this country from buying
guns in this country and killing crowds
of people in this country instead the
House of Representatives is to vote this
week to relax restrictions on buying
silencers for firearms so it becomes
more difficult to hear where the gunfire
is coming from instead we have Las Vegas
and for the website the gun violence
archive we have the 270 second mass
shooting of four or more people in this
country this year the 270 second on the
270 fourth day of the year instead we
have warmest condolences and sympathies
and we have the Second Amendment which
was designed to keep the federal
government from taking away the right of
each state to maintain its own militia
but which has now been transformed into
an excuse for why madmen of whatever
heritage or political purpose cannot be
stopped from carrying at least 10 long
rifles into a hotel room in Las Vegas
and setting up a sniper's nest and
killing people and why a group that
enables such massacres the National
Rifle Association is not branded for
what it is a terrorist organization the
gun lobby's interpretation of the Second
Amendment wrote Richard Nixon's
conservative Chief Justice of the United
States Warren Berger is one of the
greatest pieces of fraud I repeat the
word fraud on the American people by
special interest groups that I have ever
seen in my lifetime the real purpose of
the Second Amendment was to ensure that
state armies the militia would be
maintained for the defense of the state
the very language of the Second
Amendment refutes any argument that it
was intended to guarantee every citizen
an unfettered right to any kind of
weapon he or she desires the Second
Amendment doesn't guarantee the right to
have firearms
at all there are 7820 words in our
Constitution amendments included the
words right and rights appear only 15
times vote votes and voting appear only
37 times the reference is to ownership
pay payment obligation property private
property dollars compensation profit
Revenue taxes duties words like that
total 103 our Constitution is a property
document a contract and yet none of the
words in the second amendment include
any of those ownership words a
well-regulated militia being necessary
to the security of a free State the
right of the people to keep and bear
Arms shall not be infringed keep and
bear as Chief Justice burger insisted do
not mean own period the Second Amendment
is gun control and it is gun control
from an era where the gun was a musket
and not an automatic killing machine
that could be bought and stashed on the
32nd floor of a hotel in order to shoot
people five hundred at a time the
authors of the second amendment did not
address could not conceive of such arms
such instant mechanised death any more
than they could have conceived of
nuclear weapons the Second Amendment
does not give you the right to own those
either it is time to end the lies about
the Second Amendment it is time to end
refusing to call mass murderers who do
not have obvious political motives
terrorists it is time to end the
National Rifle Association and it is
time to end the career of any political
figure who made his way to the White
House dog whistling to his Second
Amendment
people we have had 44 past presidents
four have been assassinated with guns
another was shot and wounded so was
another as he tried to regain his office
seven more survived or just avoided
significant assassination
it's all with guns that's 13 out of 44
presidents and guns nearly 1/3 of them
our American history is death by gun
that must end 274 days this year and 272
shootings of four or more people at a
time no outlet of radical Islamic
terrorism could hope for such a carnage
could dare to seek so many murders of so
many Americans but we don't need to do
anything about it do we we have thoughts
and prayers and we can pretend some of
the carnage is terrorism and some of it
is not and we have a president's warmest
condolences and sympathies